the shippers are coming
[Music]
hey there folks
i'm now going to touch on a topic that i
rarely talk about and almost never
dedicate a video to
and that is a shipping pair in this case
we are talking about
phasmin which is the ship of yasmin khan
played by mandip gill and the doctor the
13th doctor specifically played by jodie
whittaker in doctor who
so
thasman was pretty much made canon
in the most recent episode that aired at
the time of recording which was eve of
the daleks you ever told her told her
what
how do you feel about it is it that
obvious or at least it was confirmed as
being canon for
yes we don't really have the doctor's
side of this yet so we don't know if
it's one-sided don't know if we're
looking at a martha and 10th doctor
situation again or not
it's like when you fancy someone and
they don't even know you exist that's
what it's like
come on
but
the reason i want to talk about this and
again something i rarely talk about
is there were some things that happened
at gallifrey one the conference i went
to in los angeles some things that were
said by certain people that really got
me thinking about it and i want to talk
about it um by the way if you don't know
about gallifrey one there is my vlog
recounting what it was like because it
was wonderful
but without getting into everything that
went on there there's two things that
are relevant to this conversation that i
want to have because i'm not really here
to talk about whether or not i think
thasman is a good idea or a bad idea
because the honest truth is
i don't like the doctor being
romantically involved with companions i
never have i didn't like it with tenon
rose i didn't like the unrequited
version with martha and ten i didn't
really like that amy had the sexual
crush on 11 for a while one of the
things i really appreciated about
capaldi's 12th doctor was that that
energy was not there anymore with his
relationship with his companion so
i'm not super in favor of this but again
that's more to do with my general
demeanor as a
grumpy bastard who does not really care
for romantic subplots
in anything
so
i'm not here to litigate whether or not
it's a good idea it's a good chip or
whatever
i do want to talk about sort of how it's
come about and look at it through the
lens of the production and the writing
and how it happened
did it happen on purpose
was it planned when was it planned and
why does that matter
so
as i said there's two main things we're
going to be talking about one
happened at a panel i was actually
personally at
and one happened at a panel that i
didn't but has been written up about and
i have sourcing on so
the uh discussions that are going to be
relevant here are from panels held by
matt strevins who is a producer on the
current hour of doctor who and the one
with amanda gill which i was at
so
in both cases the topic of this ship was
brought up um and in the case of the man
deb guild one which is the one i was
actually at that was brought
specifically up in terms of
when did you know
that this was going to happen
and in the case of the matt strevins
panel it was brought up in terms of
what made you want to decide to do this
so
the answers each of them gave
on their faces seem
a little bit contradictory
let me explain
so what matt strevin said in regards to
the entire concept of this ship was this
jody had brought it to set after the
first season and said there's
speculation out there and we hadn't
really thought about it but it became
quite a big thing and if you think about
the history of doctor who since russell
brought it back every companion story
with the doctor is a love story now i'm
just going to say really quick in
regards to that second part of that i
heavily dispute what he's saying there i
will grant insofar as if you are putting
platonic love on the table because if
you're telling me bill was romantically
in love with the 12th doctor you and i
need to go have a conversation somewhere
so i can pick your brain and figure out
where you are getting any of that but
since he's putting it in the context of
a romantic talk i just
i just heavily disagree with that very
statement but i just need to say that so
we can get it done and focus on the
first part and when i said things don't
quite line up with what mandip said i
don't have an exact quote from her
because i didn't think to write it down
at the time but what she said when riley
silverman asked her
when did you know
that it was going to happen
mandip gil said when i read it on the
page meaning in eve of the daleks when
she read that dan asks yaz about this
and yaz confesses that was the first
time she knew it was happening i've
never told anyone now on the surface
this would seem to be a little bit of a
contradiction right because we have on
the one hand matt strevin saying jody
brought it to us after the first season
and so it was in our minds
very you know from that point on which
would have meant all through series 12
and all through flux yet it wasn't
addressed until after that but mandep
gill is saying no i did not know
until eve of the daleks
so what's going on here
well
a couple of things the first is is that
i would not be surprised if in both
cases there is a mild bit of
exaggeration going on i don't think
either one is a liar but i do think that
when you're especially at something like
a panel you tweak stories so that they
are better stories
they tell better and they hit better
that's just kind of a thing that happens
whether you mean it to or not
so i would not be surprised if the
impression that matt strevins left of
them sort of jumping on the idea once
jody whittaker brought it to them and
it's also worth saying that he said
amanda uh gill was in favor of the idea
and for him to imply that like they were
working on it ever since then
maybe that was the point at which the
seed was planted
but
that doesn't necessarily mean that they
were definitely writing them that way
from there on out
but to imply that kind of makes a better
story as for mandip gill i would not be
very surprised to learn that she had an
inclination a thought a hope that maybe
they would do it prior to that reveal
but
that she didn't know for certain until
she read it but she
but she didn't imply that she had
thought it would happen too much prior
to that so between those i think that
covers the gap in understanding and so
now
let's talk about how this came about and
also it's worth pointing out some people
are like reporting this in weird ways
like i saw some headlines that said
mandip gil and jody whitaker like fought
to have it happen i'm like nothing
either of them said implied that it was
like they were pushing and were arguing
and saying like we need this to happen
like that that wording i've seen in a
few places like no that's just a
complete
mischaracterization
of what i have heard and said and read
so drop that idea
but
what appears to have happened is that
series 11 it was on nobody's minds and
then after that series aired the fan
community some of them started talking
about this idea which
all fan communities have shippers they
just do so it's not exactly a novel
thing that that happened but the fact
that it got um to the creators and that
it was specifically brought to them by
one of their stars by jody whitaker and
was sort of co-signed as an idea by
mandip gill
that's sort of what makes it a little
bit more unusual because like as i said
every fandom has its shippers this stuff
happens for every show every season all
the time forever
so
the fact that the ship exists really
isn't the thing the thing is that it got
brought to the creative team
by some of their leads which would have
given it in theory more weight for them
to actually think about doing it
we know thasman was not planned since
series 11.
everybody's story indicates that that
was not going on
so that brings us to the question of
whether or not it was planned from the
start of series 12 on
and if it was
why didn't you tell your actors
that you were doing this
because the thing that really jumped out
to me about mandep's statement was that
it meant one of two things
on its own and then matt stress kind of
narrowed it down but at the time i heard
that i thought well that means one of
two things
either
chibnall decided to do that
kind of out of nowhere and like hadn't
really thought about it before but then
just decided to do it for whatever
reason
or
it meant he'd been planning it but for
some reason thought it was a good idea
to not tell the actors who had to
portray that
and it appears to be that second one
based off what matt strevin said with
them
kind of glomming onto the idea from jody
whitaker now that doesn't mean that
right from the start of series 12 that
they that the writers when i say they in
this case i mean the writers not also
the actors that they were planning to
implement it definitely from there on
out
but
man dipkill did know that she was going
to stick around for another series after
ryan and graham left
so
that definitely feels like it might have
been building towards this thing but
then why wouldn't you tell your actors
that's the thing that strikes me as
really
really strange the only argument that i
can think of that makes
any degree of sense
is that
maybe they were afraid that she might um
spill the beans like at a con or asked
by a fan or something which i'm not
gonna say is a totally invalid fear if
that was at play mendip gill herself um
at the panel was sort of adorably antsy
about like oh what can i say what can i
say
but the thing is like she had an
awareness
she was thinking very carefully about
that and wasn't like just dropping
things and going and then going oh no i
shouldn't have said that
she was actually thinking about it as
much as it was visible that she was kind
of fretting about what she could or
couldn't say
so
i don't think this was a tom holland
situation where well we know that
they're gonna spill it so like we have
to ensure that this actor knows as
little as possible because they can't
keep their mouth shut which that's true
with tom holland with uh infinity war
and end game they had to show him the
most bare-bones scripts possible because
the guy just lets stuff drop which he
freely admits and he doesn't mean to it
just happens but that doesn't feel like
the situation that went on with mandip
gill
so i'm not sure why
she wasn't told
which actually brings me back i know i
said matt strevins indicates that they
had started writing it but just didn't
tell the actors
just because they started thinking about
the idea
after series 11 aired
doesn't mean that's when they actually
started writing it and more to the point
mandip gill was not intentionally
deliberately playing yaz
to be that way
that's kind of the thing about the fact
that she didn't know so we're looking at
one of two situations
either
the writers decided between series 11
and 12 after finding out about this that
yeah we're going to do this but then for
some reason didn't tell their actors
or that planted the idea of oh maybe
that's a thing to do later and then
watching the way in which mandip gill
was playing the part made them think
okay yeah we should do that
and what i mean by that is and this is
another thing i've seen misreported
people have been writing and saying that
like she played
the yasmine deliberately as like being
in love with the doctor hoping that
they'd make the ship real that's not at
all what she said she did say that she
made the decision
to play yaz with a sense of awe
and wonder
towards the doctor and she said that
after she became aware of the ship she
was playing it in a way that
if they ever went that direction it
could work that way
not the same thing as deliberately
playing it as love
but playing it in a way that
if they ever pulled the trigger on it
being love
the performance works for that
so we're in this bizarre situation where
the actress
and the fandom
kind of
manifested it to the writers
who then
after sitting on it for a bit did decide
to actually pull the trigger
now we've only got a couple of episodes
left to find out where if anywhere this
goes there's been assurance that it is
going to come up and be addressed in the
upcoming legend of the sea devils and i
really hope so because as we near the
end of the chibnall era
it's been frustrating how many of the
ideas the big ideas like them or not
have not actually yielded much
story
the
redestruction of gallifrey
has not really yielded any direct
stories
the timeless child
has
barely come up again and when it has
it's kind of been punted as if well
we'll deal with that later like you have
almost no time left
but you're not actively engaging with
these ideas and i would hate
the idea as much as i'm not a shipper
and i don't love the idea of the doctor
being in romantic relationships with the
companions or even them being one-sided
as much as i don't like that idea
if you're gonna have it
explore it
do something with it you're running out
of time
and that i feel
is
indicative of chibnall's era as a
showrunner more than anything else
that these ideas
while i can't say definitively they
aren't planned
the planning doesn't seem to actually
extend out very far
like the plan of what to do
after this thing that you built up to
like the timeless child happens okay so
what now
uh or you know the lack of planning in
the sense of
this whole thasman thing and the fact
that
the actress
didn't
know
so
again either you
made a late decision to make it canon
even though you knew about it much
sooner
or you just didn't tell her
what she was going to be playing
i
neither one is great
but
i guess it's it's a difference between
a sort of
roughshod production style where
there isn't nearly as much of a plan as
you are
implying and sort of
um
letting the world think which would be
the
he you know just didn't tell her until
he decided to firmly pull the trailer
yeah why not that that scenario
indicates
a production that was not nearly as
planned as as a lot of us thought or
that chibnall himself implied
like even before the first episode aired
chimney was talking about his plan how
much he had planned what a plan it was
but
if that's the case then we're looking at
a situation where
there was not
that much planned or if or the things
that were planned
were just kind of bullet points and the
plan didn't extend out it didn't extend
out very far
as far as um well how do we get there
and then what do we do with it once we
got there
or alternately
it was planned and then that
gives us a production where
the plan itself
and the way to go about executing it
doesn't make a ton of sense
because as someone who's done acting
you don't
not tell
your actors
what emotions they're supposed to be
playing
if you know what you're gonna do like i
understand not wanting to drop major
plot points until that are going to
happen later but if you know what you're
building towards
they kind of need to know when it's an
emotional core
of what they're doing
which i think is why for some people
like some people when the whole thing
happened in eve the dalek some people
were very like yes i've been seeing this
in the performance and you have because
as i said mandep gill was playing it in
a way that could be read that way and
she was doing it deliberately even
though again by her words did not
indicate to me that she specifically
wanted it to be interpreted definitely
that way but there was something there
you weren't seeing in nothing at least
not from series 12 into flux but then
there were others and i'm not going to
say i was completely
in this camp but i was closer to this
camp there were others who felt it came
out of nowhere
and in a way
it did
we're in this bizarre almost
schrodinger's relationship situation
where it both was
and wasn't planned
was and wasn't
built up to
and it's just fascinating for me to talk
about because it explains why
there was
such a split between people
who definitely saw this coming and
people who said this came out of nowhere
and they're both right in a way
what a strange situation
again no judgment on quality i hope it
goes somewhere i hope they do something
with it but
man that's weird
and interesting
and fun to talk about
so
what are your thoughts do you think i've
misread this situation and what did or
didn't happen like i'm throwing
possibilities i didn't say definitively
what i think it was but
do you think there's another possible
read on this that isn't any of the ones
i've given
what are your thoughts on this ship in
general
what are you looking forward to in
legends of the sea devils i'm honestly
just kind of looking forward to the sea
devils i like the sea devils whatever
your thoughts are drop something down in
the comments let's talk about it patreon
is how i pay the bills any amount you're
able to give does help me out
immensely
like i was able to go out to galford one
at all
because of support on my patreon
but
even if you're not able to do that
there's other things to follow me on
other places on the internet or just the
like share and subscribe they help as
well
but um
don't worry about it too much
what i really want you to remember
is that
shipper or not
you are beautiful
you are valid
and you are loved
you're the council i'm just running the
meetings and until next time this
council
is adjourned
[Music]
it's the end credits means i got to
shout out some patrons this month it is
turok oliver b linda walters tt
robin powell fronabilax the poodle idoln
tracy scrabbon dharma michael doyle
vincent paul bartolucci angry casper
adam lefty taylor robin moore shayla
gourlay and bookworm
thanks so much for your support
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
bye
[Music]